welcome back to las vegas now well may
is mental health awareness month but
this is something we really should be
talking about all year long so joining
us today is melody parker of mending
broken pieces counseling and consulting
services hi melody
hello how are you i'm great how are you
i'm well thank you well thank you so
much for joining us this is a really
important conversation to have so let's
get right to it what are some things
that we can be doing to you know look
out for our mental health
well as you stated yes it is mental
health awareness month and it is so
important to take care of ourselves so
just a few things one talk about your
feelings
get into a space where you can talk
about it freely whether it's to a
professional or to a friend someone that
you trust
because sometimes it's just hard to deal
with everything that's going on in the
world
keep active exercise
boost up your self-esteem really helps
when you're exercising and it keeps the
brain from just being overwhelmed by
negativity and eat well a healthy diet
it doesn't mean you have to eat brains
or not brain but
brussels sprouts every day you know you
can have a cheat day but if you eat well
it helps with clarity and body
functioning drink sensibly
you can have a glass of wine you can go
hang out with the friends but make sure
you're choosing how you drink
and also keep in touch
being in the pandemic you know we lost
connections with others so send a text
do a facetime or call somebody just
reach out and stay connected with people
that love and support you another thing
to consider is ask for help sometimes we
get overwhelmed with how we feel and we
have all these plans that we want to
accomplish it's okay if you don't know
and to reach out and ask for help
yeah i think it's really all about
balance right melanie sorry to jump in
there but i i'm kind of seeing that
common thread here thread here that you
know it's okay to indulge a little bit
and
let loose and enjoy but it's also
important to you know take care of
yourself right
yes
and in doing so take a break like we're
always on the go busy doing this
scheduled for this meeting and that
but it's okay to just slow down take
your actual lunch break
if you can
you know just go out and explore nature
take a vacation
do something for you and just take a
break and it's really important right to
be able to talk about it i know that was
the very first thing you said i think we
are headed in the right direction to be
a little bit more open about our
feelings and communicate when we're
struggling but would you say that's the
the number one thing when it comes to
mental health is just finding someone to
confide in
yes because trust is everything and
you're exposing yourself so letting
someone know all there is to know about
you in a judgment-free zone and it's
really hard to find somebody that you
jail well with so you can do your
research there are all different types
of websites like psychology today
therapy for black girls therapy sites
that you can go and look up a therapist
in your neighborhood or maybe close to
where you work and see if they accept
your insurance or not maybe they have a
fighting skill but yeah choose somebody
who you think will fit
well melody these are all really helpful
tips and just really quickly you have an
upcoming event right tell us about that
yes so i'm partnering with a colleague
of mine her name is vicky and we're
doing grounded connected and rooted just
to help individuals reset and this will
be a face-to-face event to really just
stay connected to identify those things
that we need to reset our minds and our
bodies and that will start in september
well melody thank you so much and for
more information you can visit mending
broken counseling
those are really really helpful tips